are you really in the Navy well man it
was nice knowing you
[Applause]
what are we really gonna do how do we
expect to be Russia here war with his
sexuality this is unbelievable man how
long have you been your friend
over here I supported the four years
good for you man God bless man that's a
beautiful thing y'all a cute couple what
are you doing that's cool
you're in med school oh you look young
man good for you what doctor are you
gonna be studying dicks I bet with that
bandana
anyway
that's not a doctor bro that's a doctor
to white people that ain't a doctor to
me what's your PhD in at least something
science
materials engineering what does that
mean
you 3D print aluminum seal you a factory
worker
I can talk about PhD give it over the
Detroit Union over here out of here